welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division just confirmed
surprising new details about the marvel
timeline
after avengers in game that the avengers
medlin is still
settling i forced it but i'm happy with
it episode four
opened with the events of monica rambo
returning from the blip taking place
concurrently
with the avengers undusting the dust at
an end game and wanda's west view crisis
turns out is taking place
only a few weeks after her duel with
thanos before spider-man fought for home
then hey say what you will about me
digging back up the grave of
endgame for its infinite unresolved
questions
but like wanda recycling corpses clearly
the mcu ain't done
beating a dead horse either and thanks
to trap light games for sponsoring this
video use my link below to download
battle legion today let's break down
juan division's updates to the mcu
timeline post
endgame because this really changes a
lot of our assumptions about marvel's
shift from the infinity saga and phase
three to the multiverse saga in phase
four i'm also going to talk about paul
bettany's reveals about a deleted
in-game post-credits scene with visions
corpse because we
might now see that in one division gross
okay wanna vision episode four opens
with the dramatic re-materialization of
monica rambo the moment bruce banner
snapped everyone back
and then next scene after the credits is
monica showing up to work at sword where
hayward confirms it has been
three weeks since those events it's been
three weeks and you're the first to
report
and then next it seems like monaco makes
it a west view the next day she gets
sucked into west view and then 24 hours
after that
sword has set up camp so despite the
calendar inside the pocket reality
showing
august 1961 outside of west view in this
world the month
is november 2023 end games final battle
takes place in october 2023. how do we
know this
the mcu timeline is admittedly muddy
full of
inexplicable contradictions but the
broad
consensus from those of us who have
spent the past several years of our
lives studying this like freaks
is that these titles are generally set
around when they release
unless their story requires them to be
set right before or
right after some other event like how
black panther is set right after
t'chalka's death in civil war
set around summer 2016 despite releasing
in spring 2018 black widows doing a
similar thing releasing in 2021 we hope
despite being set sometime between 2016
and 2018
infinity war is set in may 2018 and we
know that because vision and wanda have
been on the run for exactly
two years after they fled following
civil war back in 2016. for two years
we stormed these moments trying to see
if this could work
but wait doesn't infinity war take place
right after thanos forces find the
asgardians in the ragnarok post credit
scene well yes
ragnarok is set in 2017 two years after
hulk left earth in age of ultron in 2015
but that asgardian ship has been slowly
traveling for several
months
setting that post-credit scene and
thanos's ensuing massacre
in may 2018. end game opens in the
direct
aftermath of thanos's snap with tony
coming home
23 days later it's been 23 days since
thanos came to earth
and then after the avengers fail to
avenge we jump
ahead five years later to the year 2023
but really it's five years and change
because the following
summer in spider-man far from home june
2024
betty brant says this and eight months
ago a band of brave heroes brought us
back
eight months previous would be october
2023
that is when the final battle then game
goes down when juana maximov
returns and tells thanos you took
everything from me and then after the
battle she commiserates with
hawkeye you know i wish there was a way
that i could let her know that we won
she knows
they both do and then three weeks after
this wanda is doing
this [ __ ] in west view new jersey
november 2023
so by saying they both do wanda was
signaling that vision's presence
is still very much on her mind and in
her broken heart
and today's video is brought to you by
battle legion the fun mass battle mobile
game available on ios and android
battle legion is a battle strategy game
with exciting 100 vs 100 unit pvp
battles
you design your own army and then you
set them loose
and watch the battle unfold oh my little
death knights are all grown up there are
tons of different kinds of units with
unique mechanics all customizable with
skins and power stones
play in multiple game modes main pvp
modes skirmish puzzles
bounty hunt mini missions and they just
added clan raid battles
in the most recent update join with your
whole clan to beat epic bosses
new game modes units and ranks are
coming and the game has
a very active discord community and
weekly streams on youtube battle legion
is free to download use my link below to
download battle legion today
so what happened in those three weeks
before she shows up in west view
well paul bettany revealed in a recent
interview that there was
a deleted post-credits scene to avengers
in-game that would have shown wanda
retrieving vision's corpse
at one point there was going to be a tag
um
where you opened a sort of bodybag
drawer
and there was the vision kevin kind of
talked to me and said
i just i gotta pull the shots and based
on trailer footage of wanda
in an unidentified facility those rows
and rows of drawers might be some kind
of sword
morgue swordmorg and we are watching the
moment she broke
in and stole vision's corpse this could
actually be a secure facility that
stores old weapon tech
for fear that vision's remains could be
weaponized thus
sentient weapon observation and response
division and why hayward shifted their
plans to nanotech
and ai technologies they could have
derived from vision's corpse
wanda might have followed that
conversation with klint by recovering
visions corpse
and then brought it to west view new
jersey where she created a hex based
pocket reality
in which he appears to be alive once
more why westview new jersey well
we know westview began really as the
location of jimmy wu's missing witness
something weird is going on there jimmy
says his associates now claim to have
never heard of him
i'm thinking this mystery man could have
been what led wanda to coming to west
view in the first place
perhaps some devilish plot with agnes
that i've pitched in pretty much every
other one division video
perhaps hayward knew wanda stole
vision's corpse which would be a kind of
sword scandal that he's now trying to
contain
and he used wu's missing witness to lure
in wanda to trade wanda to him
to get vision's remains back and now
that wanda has taken control of the
situation it's all going public
it's super embarrassing for him causing
him to want to flee back to hq
get me a transport back to headquarters
now we'll see what happens with one
division but
yes one division in november 2023 is
taking place
about seven months before spider-man far
from home
in june or july 2024 why
well for two reasons one i think this
could be to set up the background of the
secret invasion clues and far from home
like the scrolls which do get brought up
in jimmy wu's notes
and that space station which might be
under construction
in sword's massive hangar and could
totally be sent up to orbit on those
launch pads over the course of the next
seven months
but the other reason is to tie into far
from home's mentions of the multiverse
remember peter's excitement over
mysterio's lie
about being from the multiverse and
quentin beck's later confession that
people these days are super willing to
believe that narrative
of someone coming from an alternate
reality both of these suggest that
some event beyond endgame which didn't
exactly feature any public reveals of
the existence of a multiverse but rather
this westview anomaly
could have been what opened the eyes of
all of society the society at least in
far from home that the multiverse is
very
real and that might confirm that the
radiation of west view may expand
far beyond new jersey into a global
avengers level threat that makes the
multiverse a household term
yes i am wearing our latest obsession
shirt an unusual couple
it's got some cool easter eggs hidden in
the design that you can only see via ar
a limited supply is still available at
our merch store newrockstarsmerch.com
and thanks again to traplightgames for
sponsoring this video use my link in the
video's description to download battle
legion today
follow me on instagram eddie avas follow
new rockstars subscribe to new rockstars
on youtube breakdowns of
everything one division related thank
you for watching bye
you